hallo und herzlich willkommen zu sallys
welt ich bin als ich bin heute ein
bisschen farbe ins spiel wird erst mal
unsere gastgeberin gesprochen
hallo herzlich willkommen zur welt es
beschweren sich immer manchmal kinder
wenn ich das nicht sagen deswegen ich
muss das auch sagen und es ist alex
unser freund aus berlin
allerdings hat auch einen youtube-kanal
mister helfersyndrom und wir backen
heute zusammen aber falcon war ganz kurz
mal in einen kanal hast du denn so alles
macht was geht
liebe leute alles hier und wir heute
wieder fünf coole apps für euch
und wir haben uns überlegt heute backen
wir mal zusammen was ich weiß du isst
gerne backen gebacken hast du noch nicht
in meinem werk erfahrung beschränkt sich
bei auch mal über die schulter schauen
ok und weil er heute abend auch noch zu
seiner oma fährt immer gedacht packen
wir die leckere torte und zwar gibt es
eine schokoladentorte mit mascarpone
creme und früchten also ein richtig
schöner tag gestern
na ja auf jeden fall zeige ich mal kurz
die zutaten
wir haben hier sehr eier etwas vanille
extrakt salz ich habe 200 gramm zucker
200 milliliter mineralwasser und 200
milliliter öl 250 gramm mehl 50 gramm
kakaopulver 100 gramm speisestärke und
ein päckchen backpulver starten wir
direkt ich würde sagen du machst ist ein
syrisch kommt dass man also zuerst
kommen die eingerichtete als ein viertel
extrakte panasonic wie besoffen sondern
ganz kleinen schluck stoppt das
konzentrat deswegen dann der zucker noch
mit dazu
und jetzt geht es erstmal bei höchster
stufe für etwa vier minuten verrührt das
schaffen wir raum die friesischen profis
erstmal langsam unternehmen gezogen ja
erstmal langsam sehen
es geht auf
es ist richtig schön cremig geworden
doch schon ja doch kannst du nur eier
und zucker zwei flüssigkeiten dazu hier
einst noch dunkel und es macht halt den
teig extrem saftig und locker fluffig
nein ich mag wirklich nicht jetzt wird
es ganz ganz normal eingerührt und du
kannst ihn deshalb schon mal vor die
trockenen zutaten hierfür berühren also
alle so zum mehl mit rein und ich kann
nämlich schon mal hier meine praktische
umsetzung genau so wenn es rein passt
aber so ein bisschen kaka muss nicht
unbedingt nochmal gleich dazu ich kann
schon mal die backformen vorbereiten und
zwar backes in 20 cm form allerdings
nehme ich drei backformen und zwar
möchte ich dass diese torte richtig
schön hoch wird aber wenn jetzt keine
drei backformen habt könnt ihr auch
einfach zum beispiel der 24er form
nehmen und den teig auf einmal packen
und später einfach durchschneiden
aber ich will ich finde sie dann cool
aus unserer drei teigschichten und dann
zweimal creme
deswegen mache ich drei optionen genau
wie schlage jetzt kurz den bug 4 1 dann
merkt keinen zeitraum
jetzt sieben wir die trockenen zutaten
her nein das darf doch nicht so hierauf
gibt keine blümchen schlossen
ach komm mach du das wenn ich sauer
reagieren kannst du dir das schiff nicht
auf dich
doch gesiebt rapper pulver eben mal kurz
durch
also du stellst dich besser an den der
küche als der markt muss ich schon sagen
dankeschön dankeschön aber sie muss noch
ein bisschen besser ist ich sagen ja
das lassen wir ihn auch noch mal ganz
kurz einrühren
bei niedriger stufe geht aber auch einem
schneebesen aber wenn man jetzt schon
hier stehen haben
warum ich
und ich teile den fertigen teig jetzt
auf die drei backformen auf aber wie
gesagt könnte auch in einer backform
backen in der größeren hat er hier so
einen coolen ausgeschmückt
das profi equipment jeden tag in der
küche packt nun sich sona lohnt sich
meint einmal zu weihnachten tolles paket
mit geschenken echten schlechtes
gewissen tante monika bis einmal benutzt
online kannst du gleich dann zu hause
wenn der kuchen schmeckt oder die tote
ganz gleich nochmal beim recyceln
schaffe mir die kommentare hier kommt
über sie probiert das rezept so war es
für euch geworden dass inflationieren
wir das auch möchte probiert und ob sich
gelegt vor allem hatten wir gestern
schon drüber ich würde auch mal gerne
wissen wie viele leute überhaupt was
nach backen oder jedes rezept oder jedes
zweite oder das wäre schon mal cool so
'ne zusammen zu wissen kostenzuschuss
bilder manchmal vielleicht auf instagram
auf facebook guck ich mir das immer an
dann krieg ich selber wieder gelöst da
muss wieder auf neues banken 1 bekommst
du es nämlich ich habe den open schon
vorgeheizt und da werden die böden jetzt
bei mir bei 170 grad ober unterhitze für
etwa 20 minuten gebacken
je nach bank formats mit größerer form
hat müssen natürlich länger backen so um
die 30 35 minuten auf jeden fall die
stäbchen probe mit dem zahnstocher nicht
vergessen und wir wollen dann kurz auf
nicht einfach doch drauf stellen
kuchen böden sie nichts gebacken ich
hab's ja auch schon komplett abkühlen
lassen und wäre sogar die zwischenzeit
genug unseren anderes video zu drehen
und zwar haben wir fünf coole apps ums
thema ernährung und gesundheit gedreht
und die könnt ihr beim alex auf dem
kanal finden beim ist der hörer sind um
und der stelle der alex stellt alle zehn
tage sogar apps vor also ich finde es
richtig cool so ist und die findet sich
wirklich gut geschlagen also ein nettes
video ganz lustig genau ich zeige euch
jetzt was und die raucher jetzt noch die
zutaten für die creme und zwar machen
wir eine maske ab ohne sahne creme und
dann kommt da fürchte rein und hier
stehen schon gezahlt hatten
ich habe 500 gramm mascarpone ich
brauche dann ab 850 gramm puderzucker
etwas vanille extrakt für das leckere
aroma und zwei becher sahne das sind 400
gramm und an früchten nehmen wir
brombeeren und kirschen und hier habe
ich noch etwas kirschsaft man könnte
natürlich auch kirschwasser benutzen bis
geschwister nicht geschluckt
ja deswegen deswegen nämlich geschafft
und kirschwasser wird so ein bisschen an
schwarzwälder kirschtorte erinnern
stehen hätten so schwarz lackierten
style getötet hier störte mich eine
konstante oder sein was das ist sein
part ist susanne steifen und dadurch für
die sahne schneller steif besser steif
und die traute bleibt später im
anschnitt auch schön etwas passt ganz
gut weil du nimmst damit so der oma
deswegen so ich nehme jetzt aber zuerst
mal die sahne und schleift schlag die
steiff das mache ich hier in der
küchenmaschine aber andere gerät geht
natürlich auch
du machst es an geheimen handwerk gelegt
mache ich muss selber musste kraft wenn
du da gebe ich gleich zwei teelöffel
vier teelöffel seiner fahrt meter zu und
ich lasse sie schon mal schweiz schlagen
und du kannst in der zeit ein paar
kirschen entsteinen und zwar sind die
schon gewaschen und die ganz schöne
legte mir weg die brauchen wir für die
dekoration reicht die maschine
nein habe ich schon das ist ganz ganz
schöne länger weghaben die angst und
jürgen blomen müssen kinder und die
anderen kannst du dann entsteinen alles
schön sich auch gerade ja gut anlegen
jetzt einfach ein paar weg gut durch das
genau dann weiß man einfach hier den
stil wegnehmen und es gibt natürlich
auch kerschensteiner aber ich finde das
traumauto kannst du einfach hier so
einrichten nach combé htm selbst
einzelne nation mit dem kern 20 einen
neuen baum in dem hochbeet das kannst du
dann den kern kurs am besten was
wirklich mitnehmen deshalb zu machen und
ich suche nur ein paar kirschen gleiche
aus zum weglegen und schlage zumal die
sache stellen
ich habe die sahne steif geschlagen die
steht im kühlschrank damit sie nicht
zusammenfällt und jetzt gebe ich die
mascarpone hier in eine rührschüssel
während alex noch mit den kirschen
beschäftigt sich ein bisschen nur durch
die reuse gar nichts tun ist mir total
viel arbeit ab ich gebe jetzt noch wann
extrakt mit dazu man könnte jetzt noch
andere aromen mit reinbringen was auch
ganz gut passt wer bittermandel zum
beispiel so mit kirschen finde ich
bittermandel passte ganz gut
puderzucker gebe ich auch mit rein was
auch immer was auch immer und jetzt
verrichtet ganz kurz und gibt da noch so
etwa 3 telefon seiner partner dazu
jetzt gebe ich einen teil von der saane
mit mascarpone creme und rühre sie
einmal kurz einem schneebesen unter
damit sie sich schön mit der masse ab
ohne verbindet
die mascarpone kriegen sind fertig ich
habe es hier auf so einen kühl pad
gestellt weil sie drin schon ziemlich
warm ist ich weiß die es nicht so warm
wie mir aber ich hoffe mal mit zwei
tagen auch im sommer ich bin total froh
winter decke geben auf jeden fall löst
sich jetzt den torten rahmen mit einem
fahrtenmesser wenn mein gesicht nicht zu
verstauen wirken das als wiki was du
hast hast du für alles was besonders
diese abschneidet maschine habe mich
heute schon bei der jetzt nehme ich den
tortenboden mit sonderfahrten retten
runter und setzen auf eine tortenplatte
das ist das ganz normales und weil jetzt
noch etwas geschmack mitnehmen möchte
kann den tortenboden noch etwas trinken
der ist zwar schon relativ saftig arbeit
könnt ihr auch hier gerne etwas
kirschwasser nehmen oder kirschsaft wenn
ihm natürlich kirschsaft und macht man
dann einfach mit so einem pinsel und
rollen
auch nicht so viel
und dann kommt schon die leckere creme
drauf und zwar muss ich mir die jetzt
aufteilen in zwei portionen und ich aber
drei würden
und die kommt immer nur zwischen
rheineck also von außen sieht man dann
auch diese einzelnen schichten und wir
machen da nichts nach außen rum
deswegen habe ich jetzt auch keinen
torten rahmen des darf ruhig so ein
bisschen
jetzt verstehe ich den begriff bedeutet
dass da nicht viele verzierungen oder
verzierungen aber genau so eine nackte
terror und von außen darf man dann eben
auch ruhig sehen
und jetzt darfst du mir wieder helfen
und es war verteilen jetzt ein paar
früchte
du kannst auch gerne die kirchen gehen
müssen aufpassen nicht für die same
ausdrücke genau nicht zu weit nach außen
so die haut noch ein paar kirschen rain
man sind die gut geschnittenen die sind
richtig so gleichmäßig
dann kommt der zweite boden drauf und
zieht er jetzt schon richtig gut aus und
jetzt ist gleich nochmal die reihenfolge
das hier treffen dann kommt dieser dann
die früchte denn dann das dach dann das
da
da jetzt noch der deckel drauf sind es
unter das macht einfach so sieht schon
mal sehr gut aus aber die torte muss
jetzt leider noch mal kurz im
kühlschrank und zwar für eine stunde
damit wir sie gleich noch fertig
dekorieren kann
warum dürfen wir jetzt nicht essen
wollte noch nicht fertig ist die
dekoration finden aber warum muss sie da
vor dem kühlschrank
genau damit ein wird dieser noch mal
schön fest wird kalt wird ich dachte es
macht dieses pulver wird ja das macht
unsere torte ist es mittlerweile schön
kalt und bewertet noch eine schöne
schokocreme darüber streichen und samira
volt übrigens die gleichen haare wieder
alex noch haben wir die leitungen blond
sehr schützen über sich und für uns der
schafe creme alex braun wir nur zwei
zutaten und zwar 100 schoko mit der
schokolade ganz genau und ich gibt es
jetzt hier mal kurz in den topf also die
sahne die wird kurz aufgekocht
ja aber erst einmal aufkochen lassen die
kostet auf und nehmen ist vom herd
darunter dann sind sie nur noch 95 km 1
die zahl ist jetzt aufgekocht jetzt
gibt's da noch die schokolade mit rein
und dann werde ich jetzt so lange rühren
bis sich alles schön verbunden hat ein
bisschen schokolade geschmolzen kommt
das ist erstmal machen
die schoko sahne fühle ich jetzt immer
lass dir ganz kurz abkühlen und dann
können wir gleich unsere früchte nehmen
die torte holen und dekorieren ist
unsere torte fertig allerdings haben wir
gerade 2000 vor uns stehen denn passiert
und zwar ist die torte im kühlschrank
einfach in sich zusammengefallen
ich kann jetzt eigentlich nur so
erklären dass die tortenböden etwas zu
locker warm das heißt ich hab sie nicht
lang genug ausruhen lassen weil ich hab
sie einfach bei zimmertemperatur
ungefähr eine halbe stunde abkühlen
lassen und die creme war er auch noch
relativ warm und deswegen solltet ihr
auf jeden fall so wie ich bei meiner
zweiten torte die tortenböden richtig
abkühlen lassen vielleicht kurz im
kühlschrank geben so für eine halbe
stunde und die creme bevor sie auf die
torte gestrichen wird auch noch kurz im
kühlschrank
aber das ist gar nicht schlimm ich
wollte einfach zeigen dass mit es auch
mal passieren kann und ich finde da
waren wir später einfach so ein löffel
des heraus als team das mich total
lecker sind nicht ganz so toll aus sieht
so aus hätte man es mit gewalt kaputt
machen fische loch und die zarte ist
einfach kaputt aber wir führen das
später in gläser rein und dann kann man
das so nah schmeckt wirklich lecker na
ja ich stelle euch die mal kurz auf die
seite
aber was mache ich jetzt am besten ganz
kurz werden schon genug missgeschicke
und diese schokoladencreme habe ich
jetzt etwa so eine halbe stunde noch mal
abkühlen lassen
in der zeit hat
zugleich nutzt sie nehme ich ihn oben
gleich so ein bisschen runter laufen
passiert immer noch aus welt zählt immer
noch als merkels kind weil man sieht ja
am rand immer noch aber wir lassen jetzt
schön runter laufen
und jetzt setzen wir noch die früchte
rein und zwar ziemlich in die mitte okay
also so dass wegen der mitte so ein berg
an früchten haben
es war zum anschneiden bisschen
schwierig aber ich finds halt schön
sieht echt schön auf die strecke hier
ist man auch die hände lassen wir jetzt
auftreten mit kern nicht so ganz
sorgfältig so ein bisschen darf aussehen
als etwas drauf geschmissen aber
eigentlich ganz schön gelegt
und bevor wir die torte anschneiden
stellen wir sie noch mal ungefähr für
ein halbe stunde im kühlschrank und
wieder ja aber nur damit die schott
kriegen wir ein bisschen fest wirklich
in der zwischenzeit kann ich schon meine
fotos machen schon genau
alex ist man gleich probieren ich wenn
die tortur ist richtig gut aus genau
jetzt mal an echten ticketing oder
flächen kirchen
das letzte jetzt ein wenig glück
probieren
super ich weiß nicht wo ich probieren
soll das ding so groß wurden von allem
so ein bisschen geschichte
ich probiere ich nicht so gern vor der
kamera
unser wunsch wäre würde ich ihn fürchten
so schön locker nötig
tut mir leid aber ich finde es passt
richtig gut also wir haben richtig
schönen schokoladigen dunklen lockeren
teig leckere helle mascarpone creme und
danach die früchte perfekte kombination
du ich hab mir in bestimmten fällen auch
wenn mal der alex backt mal andersrum
gehört genau wie der oma was mit und
sachsen auf jeden fall whisky schmeckt
man suchen und wenn ihr das rezept nach
wochen nachmachen wollt geht einfach auf
meinen blogs ellis blog.de da geht es
noch mal die genauen zutaten mengen und
ich danke dir dass du dabei war und alex
und ich wir haben es noch zwei weitere
videos gedreht beziehungsweise drehen 1
noch gleich fertig und zwar geht einmal
um das sap system ja genau und dass die
das video mit den apps für die kinder
geht es bei mir auf dem kanal und das
andere video wie es bei dir war jetzt
kann mit der längsten bis zunächst nur
ca
wirklich leckeren schoko aber der
schmeckt nicht nur im flugzeug
beschreibt
apa
mama video